garpa vs former Admiral kuzan why and
how koozan joined Blackbeard the insane
conclusion to the Blackbeard Pirates vs
hard Pirates fight the fates of Law and
Blackbeard and more is covered in this
insane chapter plus a crazy unexpected
Soo long transformation so make sure to
stay tuned for that if you do enjoy
seeing these one piece reviews and want
to keep them coming channel the GARP
within and ground pound that like button
until you see fireworks make this the
video you joined to knock them if you
haven't already by subscribing and
hitting that notification Bell to turn
on all notifications so you don't miss
future one piece videos and updates and
now we jump into the chapter where we
left off last time with the consequences
of garp's insane punch we get an awesome
panel of Garb showing off his mighty
hockey infused fist we see the rubble
from the damage garplan sticks the
landing and there's worry about the
battleship crashing down after him it
may not be pretty but the ship does land
more or less fine as well we're gonna
see another famous ship later that
doesn't get off so well just a side note
but gotta love the dog with the bone in
his mouth at the front of garbage trip
it's awesome and as we were marveling at
garp's attack last chapter we commented
on whether he still got it or if he's
past his prime because it definitely
didn't look like he was past his Prime
with that attack but he is 78 older than
Whitebeard was when he died GARP seems
to answer this question hyping up his
own Prime strength even more in the
process he says I can't accept this in
size say it's absolutely gotten weaker
referring to his City destroying attack
the bystanders are blown away by the
power of the attack and tell him to quit
the jokes then Kobe appears running
towards GARP and GARP says Hey Kobe so
you're safe and helmeppo cries again at
seeing Kobe I love to hear kujaku speak
she says to GARP that that was Overkill
and that GARP is a bad boy they keep
emphasizing the precious Apprentice
angle between GARP and Kobe which is a
cool Dynamic that I'm enjoying Kobe
notices that all these people came who
aren't even in sword he buddy comments
that Kobe's ankle shackles won't come
off and that they're at their wits end
she wants to ask if Kirk can do
something about it but then we see
garp's shock the eye then we see that he
buddy has been frozen it's a very
powerful panel spooky even it's like the
love love fruit though and just because
she's been frozen for now doesn't mean
she can't be released Again by the user
and I think we all know who the user is
and that's really hyping on itself for
now though building up the drama of the
situation people are freaking out both
Kobe and kujiku can't help but scream
while GARP just looks with that serious
expression next thing as expected he's
face to face with former Admiral and
almost Fleet Admiral kuzan this is quite
the turn and gives a much better chance
than the Blackbeard Pirates than they
had without kuza last chapter even
though GARP is GARP I mean enough said
but as he says he's past this Prime and
if anyone can take him down or at least
fight him to a standstill until
reinforcements come it's the guy that
almost became Fleet Admiral Kobe looks
mad perhaps even scared while GARP
simply looks disappointed at seeing
kuson and this will make sense in a bit
kuzan says that that's no good Kobe
can't have you running away while teach
isn't here I don't know about you but to
me kuzan versus GARP is one of the most
hype matchups and I am mad excited to
see it and we will soon but first we
jump into an interesting flashback we
are first told that two years earlier
there was a great conflict between the
Admirals Akai Inu and aokiji over who
would become Fleet Admiral we already
knew this obviously and AKA inuwan and
this flashback takes place one year
after that so kuzan has lost against
sakazuki at this point and as expected
he's not loving life right now we see
that San Juan wolf has been frozen solid
Blackbeard wants to know who did this
but it's obvious only one person could
pull this off and that's alkiji he wants
aokiji to undo his powers but it's funny
how aokiji responds it's so honest he
just says that Blackbeard should
understand as the captain he asks do you
really think I was the one who started
it and besides as I'm sure you're aware
on top of being heartbroken over things
I'm on the edge right now picture sure
for yourself who wasn't the wrong here I
love how he talks in such a low-key
reasonable way rather than jumping to
fight as we saw with Whitebeard the
guragura no me can make the user immune
to being frozen so it's kind of fitting
that Blackbeard ends up being kuzan's
Captain a little time passes and before
you know it they're laughing together
and drinking together Blackbeard is
impressed how the popsicle as he calls
him can hold his liquor and kuzan says
the same goes for Blackbeard and calls
him a filthy brute and laughs and yeah
that's a pretty great description of
Blackbeard I must say the two are
clearly having a good time though by
this point kuzan has unfrozen the
Blackbeard Pirates and he's sitting
around with the crew and they are all
having a really good time kuzan talks
about how he lost the leg that he has to
make up for with his size Powers while
sakazuki must have been wounded all over
then they talk about the burn Scar and
how the man with the burn scar is
supposed to have one of the road
poneoglyphs kuzan says maybe that's him
since he's got a scar now but Vasco
laughs saying he's just fresh off
getting his Lafitte says that the man
rides a pitch black ship it in solves
enemy ships in what is pretty much a
giant whirlpool if they get close and
it's pointed out it may be a user
ability AKA a devil fruit user and then
I love this part shiru is of the belief
that it's someone from the government
since they are real shady deep down and
thinks they held one so the Pirates can
never reach the one piece so hilarious
having the guy that's on the crew of
Blackbeard the literal dark dark fruit
user calling the world government shady
I mean it's true but it's still
hilarious aokiji pretty much says he'd
remember if he saw red poneglyph at
O'Hara but didn't he has bad memories
associated with poneoglyphs because of
what happened at O'Hara then lafeed
mentions to Blackbeard that's stealing
kuzan's ability would be a considerable
benefit to their combat strength it's
funny how kuson overhears it and says I
heard that you scum do all of you want a
visit to a world of ice he asks a pretty
awesome threat and a very literal one
Blackbeard really loses his composure
here and tells guzan to hold it going so
far as to apologize for his crewmate he
says he has no intention of doing that
in fact he asks kuzan if he wants to
join his crew some crew members think
Blackbeard is crazy but Blackbeard
sticks to his guns he says that kuzan is
basically jobless now not to mention
aimless he comments that he was driven
out by Justice but that the Justice in
their world is different kuzan says
don't be stupid just because of a few
drinks he can't trust them all of a
sudden there's no way and I gotta say if
as some people speculate kuzan is a
member of sword and was supposed to
enter the Blackbeard Army as a spy which
I've said I hope is not the case but if
it is then he should get an Oscar for
this performance it's Blackbeard being
desperate to get him on board as he
keeps playing hard to get Blackbeard
makes him an offer and asks what do you
want to do clearly for some reason or
another kuson is intrigued and as we
know eventually joins and that's the
flashback kuzan had lost his purpose to
live and become aimless while Blackbeard
appeared and gave him a new purpose and
path to pursue back back to the
president and GARP asks kuzan to turn he
buddy back to normal and to let Kobe go
he even says come back to the Navy to
kuzan but kuzan says as always you
always say everything that's on your
mind to GARP and he actually likes that
quality about him but he says he can't
Grant any of those wishes he uses ice
ball and it seems to hit GARP but garb's
hockey seems to be too strong and the
ice doesn't work on him just as it
didn't work on Whitebeard because in
that case the guragura no me's
vibrations didn't let her work but one
can assume that even his hockey was
strong enough to stop it if his devil
fruit didn't it's really an attack that
shouldn't be used against top tier
Fighters but for some reason kuzan likes
to try it it's also revealed that kuzan
is the 10th ship captain of the
Blackbeard Pirates as I anticipated
before he's definitely too strong to be
anything less that's for sure he also
asks if GARP can kill his number one
pupil which adds a further complication
here and explains why GARP looked so
disappointed earlier on like Kobe kuzan
was his pupils so we have a a pupil
versus teacher conflict going on against
the top pupil and the teacher past his
prime GARP tells his former student not
to get tied down and calls him an idiot
he says I thought I taught you to live
in the now GARP tells kuzan that those
who hesitate are weak and then he uses
Blue Hole an attack that is written as
falling to the Bottom of the Sea and we
do see how kiji falling deep in the
Earth from the attack as hockey Sparks
are shown everywhere letting us know how
strong GARP is once again so GARP is
clearly winning and man he's so fast for
how old he is but I think it's far from
over and there's even the implication at
least that's what I get from these
earlier translations that kuson may be
hesitating fighting against his former
teacher I think at the very least kusan
will be able to at least get a
standstill or Draw with GARP simply
because the latter is past this Prime
and he is his best student not to match
he could have become the fleet Admiral I
mean that's how time works usually and I
think the story calls for it as well
besides reinforcements specifically
Blackbeard reinforcements may be coming
soon as we are about to see we then jump
to the Blackbeard Pirates versus hard
Pirates battle and it actually concludes
here as I predicted it would but it's
not a total Victory as we'll see just as
yonko Shanks erased the kid pirates a
completely destroyed them in their ship
we catch up with Blackbeard and his crew
who have erased AKA destroyed the heart
Pirates we see Law's iconic hat on the
ground the ship is completely wrecked
like kids was Blackbeard even says once
you lose your ship you can't call
yourself a pirate crew anymore you've
got no way to run either and again the
also interesting and mysterious Rocky
Port incident is mentioned Blackbeard
says the 100 Pirates whose Hearts you
stole at Rocky Port even now they are
living in fear on Pirate Island when I
bring your heart back with me they'll
raise a glass in celebration dark stuff
indeed from the dark dark fruit user and
as Blackbeard and his crewmates are
standing we see law and Beppo on the
ground bleeding they look done for but
Ensure shown in manga you can never take
that for granted this is quite the feat
for Blackbeard though obviously Shanks
handled kid and crew in a split second
by himself but it's still impressive
that Blackbeard beat law who I think
most of us view as stronger than kid and
his entire crew without many of his
strongest Fighters like kuzan and all
the other ones on Pirate Island being
present hate it or love it Blackbeard
has proven that he's worthy of the yako
title once again but surprisingly
Chopper saves the day or at least takes
a total Victory away from Blackbeard
there's a flashback of him giving Beppo
something and saying I can't guarantee
at all that it'll go right okay then
there's a munching sound effect telling
us that Depot is eating something in the
meantime Blackbeard is counting his
chickens before they hatch Blackbeard is
excited thinking about what to do with
the opioid me should he use it to become
immortal or should he sell it but then
Chopper's formula activates and allows
Beppo to enter sulong form even though
the moon isn't out Beppo says don't you
dare touch my captain we get an epic
panel of him attacking the Blackbeard
Pirates and freaking out Blackbeard this
form gives him the strength to escape
with law into the water law wants Beppo
to go back since he doesn't want to
leave his crew behind but Beppo refuses
and says believe in them they were
raised in the cold harbors of the north
the implications that they'll come back
for them one day and they'll survive
until then for now though he tells law
he can't die he's begging him not to die
so you can tell that law is on the edge
of death after what Blackbeard did to
him We're told the hard Pirates were
defeated and it was a brutal defeat by
part of Blackbeard's crew and law only
escaped because of Chopra helping Beppo
so in truth Blackbeard should have had a
more complete Victory and could have
even become immortal potentially but I
think law is too much a fan favorite
character for that let me know how you
feel with this conclusion of this
intense matchup are you disappointed is
this what you expected let me know no
one can deny that the Blackbeard Pirates
are one of the strongest Crews right now
and if you want to know all of their
powers and how strong they are exactly
you don't want to miss my all 16
Blackbeard pirates and their powers
explained video link on screen right now
and in the description I'll see you
there